sometimes somebody might have that face
it's like oh I don't want to break their
heart but I gotta tell them the truth
honeybee is telling it how it is I have
been there whatever son of the outspoken
rapper got real on Instagram on Tuesday
after an old Instagram live she did
three years ago resurfaced in the clip
cardi speaks about drugging and robbing
men while working as a stripper cardi
spoke out about her experience in the
new instapoll saying quote I made the
choices that I did at the time because I
had very limited options
adding whether or not they were poor
choices at the time she went on to
explain why she hasn't addressed any of
this since that old video especially not
in her music woat there are rappers that
glorify murder violence drugs and
robbing crimes they feel they had to do
to survive I never even put those things
in my music because I'm not proud of it
and feel a responsibility not to glorify
it who knows this does a lot of people
like mean it seems like the old clip may
have started floating around again
because of cardies next big a project
she just signed on to star alongside at
Jennifer Lopez in the upcoming stripper
theme - drama hustlers the film won't
take place in the late 2000s when party
was a stripper IRL just after the
financial crisis set in and
professionals paychecks dried up now my
actress now